the joker is a character that's been
reinvented by some of hollywood's most
celebrated actors for decades from jack
nicholson's cartoonish take on the evil
doer in tim burton's classic batman to
heath ledger's iconic
dark portrayal of the troubled villain
in christopher nolan's the dark knight
to
keen phoenix's bleak and realist
interpretation and todd phillips joker
then there's jared leto's controversial
clown prince of crime
introduce a little anarchy letto took on
the role in david ayer's 2016 film
suicide squad and has now become the
first actor to get a second chance at
playing batman's sworn enemy in a
live-action movie thanks to zack
snyder's justice league
that's right with the long gas forced
either cut of justice league letter has
broken the record for a number of times
an actor has played the joker in a
live-action film
outside of live action of course that's
a different story but we're not talking
about that right now
even though you never call and never
right i still got a soft spot for you
released in march on hbo max the snyder
curt orders up a second serving of
leto's joker albeit with a few
adjustments the film gave snyder the
opportunity to take back the reigns of
the 2017 film that was notoriously
re-shot and re-edited by joss whedon
what he's delivered is a mammoth
242-minute movie taylor made to the
director's wishes
including the controversial inclusion of
leto himself but leto's presence in the
film was far from a given here's how
letto's terrifying joker came to grace
our screens with his presence
once again all of that chit chat's gonna
get jerked
oh my god to put it lightly letto's
joker from 2016 suicide squad never got
the respect the method actor had hoped
for
with some fans calling his performance
as the iconic character
the worst one they'd ever seen the film
itself was widely penned but the actors
interpretation of the role seen as a
creepy absurd and
thuggish caricature while heath ledger
was certainly a hard act to follow
posthumously winning the academy award
for best supporting actor in 2009 for
his take on the joker some fans believe
leto deserved a second chance at the
role
suicide squad director david ayer did as
well in 2020 aya tweeted my heart breaks
for jared he did magnificent work most
of it remains unseen
later referring to the editing process
undertaken by warner brothers ayah
doubled down on his sentiments
saying jared was pretty mistreated
during this no one has seen his
performance it was ripped out of the
movie
it's understandable then that snyder and
his wife deborah who also served as a
producer on justice league had to do a
little bit of lobbying to get leto's
joker included in the new cut as debra
snyder explained to the hollywood
reporter they weren't sure how the idea
would go over with studio heads she says
they forged forward anyway hoping that
the studio would be convinced when they
saw what the creative team had in mind
she said
at first it was like no and then it was
like well maybe and then zach was like
do you want to see the scene that i
worked on
it's clear both leto and snyder took a
cue from the suicide squad criticism
and decided to tone down letto's look
for the snyder cut
letto like all of the other actors who
have played the joker is an academy
award winning actor clearly capable of
taking the role in a variety of
directions
this time he brought the character to a
darker more subdued place while the
joker of suicide squad was decked out
with short neon green hair flashy grills
on his teeth and a body covered in loud
tattoos justice league's joker displays
a quieter energy emanating a sadness
similar to ledger and phoenix's
performances that simmer comparing to
brandon lee and the crow his hair is now
long and the tattoos have somehow
disappeared in an interview with the
late show stephen colbert leto called
his new character an evolution of what
had come before
and credited the new shades of his take
on the joker to zack snyder's direction
when you work with a different director
you bring out different things so or
they bring out different things in you
while the meeting between batman played
by ben affleck and joker was one of the
most highly anticipated moments of
snyder's film it turns out that the two
actors didn't even get to be in the same
room
during filming deborah snyder explained
to ign we had to shoot them separately
we had this ticking clock and we had to
get that scene shot because it had such
extensive visual effects but all of the
actor's schedules didn't align
ultimately according to deborah snyder
they got the go-ahead from the studio to
include the additional scene
it was something that zach was like
listen this is the end of our journey
here i really want to see batman and
joker
careful check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the dc
extended universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you